president Trump's support among black
voters tops 34% in a new Emerson poll a
shocking number that shockingly fits in
among several other polls showing
uncommonly high non-white support for
the Republican president this is bad
news for Democrats as impeachment
hearings wind down liberal Supreme Court
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg winds up in
the hospital and even more democratic
candidates unbelievably enter the 2020
presidential race despite the constant
negative press one thing seems clear
going into 2020 the Democrats have
nothing then Harvard and Yale students
interrupt the big football game to
protest climate change or something and
Tom heezy coats writing in The New York
Times about Colin Kaepernick gives us
the dumbest article on the Internet
today I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
a lot to get to and all of the stories
back up and sort of prove things that
I've been saying for weeks so we have to
get to them because you know how much I
hate to say I told you so we will be
saying that a lot today some very very
good news for conservatives on the
political front first I've got to thank
our friends over at ring you know how
much I love ring why two reasons one
ring makes me feel safe
makes me feel like sweet little ELISA is
safe and two ring makes me feel like a
real cool guy because I feel like I'm
living in the future this season can be
a whirlwind of deliveries visitors and
holiday travel so it is the best time of
the year to upgrade your doorbell and
keep an eye on your home no matter where
the holidays take you ring helps you
stay connected to your home from
anywhere and I mean anywhere so you can
be in your bedroom and keep an eye on
who's coming up to your door who wants
to get in who wants to drop off a
package or whatever you can also be on a
beach you can also be at the office you
can also be on another continent you can
do it from anywhere so if there is a
package delivery or a surprise visitor
let's say your mother-in-law you will be
able to see here and speak to them all
from your phone so if it's the delivery
guy you can say okay put the package
down there alright thanks very much and
if it's your mother-in-law you can stay
perfectly silent and hope that she
doesn't think that you're home if you're
on the go this season whether it's
across town or across the country you
can check in anytime for some
much-needed holiday peace of mind I
really like it you know I travel a lot
I'm on the road going to a lot of
different schools and colleges and
speaking events sweet Elise is a pretty
good shot
I definitely wouldn't mess with her when
she's got a firearm in her hands but I
want to feel extra safe I want to know
who is coming up to my door and what's
great is because of the the two-way
audio and video and because it uploads
to the cloud even if the burglar steals
your ring you'll be able to see the
video and send it around to your
neighbors and know who is coming to your
house as a listener you have a special
holiday offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a ring video
doorbell too and motion-activated
floodlight camera the starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home no
matter what this holiday season brings
with
ringg you are always home just go to
ring calm slash Knowles Cana wles that
is ring.com slash Knowles Canada wles
additional terms may apply alright we've
got a lot to get to here
big big polling news and I think all of
it combines the 30,000 foot take away
the Democrats have nothing
they've been blustering and blustering
and blustering with impeachment with the
election with everything with the
polling with the demographics with the
suburban with all right and it just
appears that they have nothing I'm not
saying that Democrats won't win in 2020
they might but what I am saying is that
the Democrats don't think that they're
gonna win in 2020 why some really really
bad news came in yesterday for them
Trump is doing historically well among
non-white voters according to polls now
I want to remind you some people said
months and months ago and and now I
guess years ago Trump is doing well
among black voters and Hispanic voters I
was one of those people
Candace Owens was one of those people
and the left and the independence and
the really smart guys on TV in the
jackets and ties who know everything
better than we all do they said that's a
joke that's a farce
there's no way Trump is gaining any
support among minority voters you're
just imagining and it's wishful thinking
and I kept an open mind I said okay I
guess we'll see how it plays that closer
to the election turns out according to
multiple polls Trump support among
non-white voters is significant I mean
much much higher than usual that's not
to say he's even close to getting a
majority of non-white support because
historically that's just not what
happens for Republicans but he's doing
very well so according to this new poll
from Emerson Trump has thirty four point
five percent support among black
registered voters during the Obama era
ninety percent ninety two percent voted
for Barack Obama and historically
speaking it's upwards of ninety percent
that vote for the Democratic candidate
eighty-five to ninety percent
and then maybe 10% votes for the
Republicans this is in 2016 compared to
2016 we've got 8 percent black support
for Trump
now it's up possibly 235 or 0.5 you
should take the poll a little bit with a
grain of salt this was a poll of 1092
registered voters but it was taken just
this month November 17th to the 20th the
same poll taken last month showed that
trump support was 17.8%
among blacks so it's increased pretty
dramatically why could that have
happened
well one we've seen a lot of Trump in
the impeachment hearings and impeachment
hasn't really shown any new information
it's the same phone call you got a lot
of people the key witnesses were brought
in front of Congress and they said that
there was no quid pro quo Adam Schiff
then interpret that to mean that there
was a quid pro quo so not a lot has
changed other than showing there's no
real they're there why else
there have been a lot of Democratic
candidates who have come across the
stage we've had a number of debates and
they're pretty weak it's a weak field
don't take my word for it
you've got other candidates now getting
into the race this late in the game
because of how weak the field it isn't
is not just that I subjectively consider
this Democratic field to be weak it is
objectively weak and the Democrats
themselves are more or less admitting on
this poll the margin of error is eight
point three percent because if it's a
poll of a thousand or 1,100 registered
voters the subset of those voters who
are black is much smaller it increases
the margin of error still even let's
let's use the margin of error
you got a thirty four point five percent
black support take eight points away
from that he's still doing incredibly
well 26.2 percent historically very very
high and more than three times what he
got in 2016 and it's not just black
voters it's also Hispanic voters so the
same poll showed that Trump is doing
significantly higher among Hispanic
voters than he was last month his
support among Hispanic voters looks like
it's thirty eight point two percent in
November compared to twenty six point
two percent the month earlier again why
could this be
is it possible that Democrats who have
been pandering to non-white racial
identity politics for the past 50 years
why would they be losing support what's
because their candidates are appealing
to eight not just white people primarily
but to an extraordinarily slim set of
white people look at the pitches being
made by Elizabeth Warren for instance
Elizabeth Warren the whitest woman ever
there was whiter than the newly driven
snow and she pretended to be a Native
American for her career for professional
advancement that's not gonna play very
well among even people who are typically
receptive toward Democratic racial
identity politics because she's a race
fraud and she's a race hustler but even
what she's pushing for or policies that
appeal primarily to white
college-educated suburban metropolitan
voters so just her college plan right
basically have everybody in the country
subsidized the college education of the
majority of Americans who go to college
only a third of Americans go to college
and the people who do go to college and
graduate school disproportionately white
so you're now talking to people who are
disproportionately non-white
disproportionately lower income saying
hey we're gonna take your money and use
that to pay for people who look like me
not like Native American me but white me
Elizabeth Warren that doesn't play very
well if you're playing the game of
racial identity politics how about
people to judge I think as blacks abort
is about zero percent even Saturday
Night Live made fun of this the other
day they're appealing even though they
they sort of position themselves the PR
about the Democratic Party is that
they're the party of racial diversity
they're the party playing to non-white
voters in the reality at least this
election season they're not doing that
maybe that has something to do with
these poll numbers other polls by the
way just to temper your expectations
other polls say that Trump support among
non-white voters isn't that great so
there's an economist YouGov poll around
the same time it said that it's his
support among non-white voters is about
16% morning consult and political say
that it's about 18% Gallup showed it's
about 21% so still not terrible numbers
but certainly not 34 38% however there
are other polls that agree with the
Emerson poll so according to an NPR PBS
Newshour Marist Poll this was in
mid-november around the same exact time
Trump had 33 percent approval among
non-white adults that's completely in
line with the Emerson poll how do you
explain that NPR PBS Newshour Marist is
not some conservative poll it's not some
poll that skews disproportionately
toward Republicans something is going on
there's another poll Rasmussen which
generally does favor Republicans
Rasmussen has the same number as Emerson
and as NPR PBS Newshour Marist Rasmussen
has 34% support among likely black
voters if the Democrats only pick up 65%
of black voters they're done they're
done they need to have huge outrageous
and almost exclusive control over the
black vote if they want to maintain
anything near their current electoral
dominance if Democrats lose their
non-white voters they're finished I hate
to say I told you so
I was in Kentucky giving a speech a
couple weeks ago and there was a group
of young I guess right-wing you know
ostensibly conservative they're not
really conservative but they're
definitely right-wing young right-wing
activists who call themselves the
gropers who follow this guy Nick Fuentes
who if you haven't been following it
it's kind of a sordid Internet II saga
but you know you can google you can
figure it out these are guys who engage
in white identity politics so especially
the head of it Nick Fuentes is engaging
in white identitarian ISM and suggesting
that a conservative movement needs to
appeal to white voters explicitly
primarily if not exclusively because of
the demographics this is a line that one
of the corey pers brought up to me in
Kentucky which is that demographics are
destiny me
that you will be able to predict have
someone votes on the basis of race and
it doesn't just stop there that one's
voting patterns are engrained in one's
race there's no hope to possibly change
that and so you've got to look at
politics primarily through a racial lens
rather than primarily through a
philosophical or ideological lens and I
said this isn't true because while at
any given moment you might be able to
predict how people vote based on any
sort of group characteristics including
race this is not an eternal truth what
are some examples of this in the 1930s
black people voted for Democrats and
Republicans at about the same rate this
this pattern persisted until about the
mid 1940s and then around 1947 1948
right when President Truman by the way
integrated the army then you saw this
shift that begins to go toward the
Democratic Party then throughout the
1960s when Democratic presidents JFK and
LBJ get credit for civil rights acts all
of a sudden you see this real dominance
on the Democratic Party does that mean
that black voters could just totally
switch to become Republicans overnight
perhaps that would be unlikely what it
does show you is that your voting habits
are not ingrained in your race they're
not racially determined same thing is
true of Hispanic voters so among
Hispanic voters the majority of them
vote for Democrats but among the subset
of Cuban voters the majority vote for
Republicans why is this it's obviously
because of the Cuban experience of
communism under Fidel Castro now when
they come to America they identify as
conservative they vote for Republican
this persists over successive
generations the bad news is that over
recent generations the children of these
Cuban immigrants and the grandchildren
have started to skew left again that's
bad news even though they still do vote
for Republicans generally what does that
tell us it tells us that voting habits
are not racially determined and they're
not even determined by immigrant status
because of this irony among Cuban
Americans where the grandchildren who
were born in America they're American
citizens are more likely to vote
left-wing than the immigrant
grandfathers same race right
so it's not racially determined not even
immigrant determined because the
immigrants are more likely to be
conservative
this is not to deny group
characteristics and voting at any given
point in time but what it is showing you
is that these things are not just in the
DNA and we're seeing that in these polls
President Trump has been making this
pitch
since 2016 when he made an explicit
appeal to black voters he said what have
you got to lose you've been voting for
Democrats for 50 years what's it gotten
you
vote for me give it a try what have you
got to lose he was mocked for this he
was called all sorts of names for this
and it would appear from at least these
multiple polls that it's working will
that last into 2020 I guess we'll have
to wait and see I think the Democrats
are worried that it's going to last into
2020 because they are scurrying now to
find a new candidate their current
candidates are insufficient they are
inadequate I think you could nominate
any of these candidates that they have
up there today Joe Biden Liz Warren
Peabody judge and I think Donald Trump
would win 57 states I think it would be
he would win Greenland okay so they're
worried about this you've got new
candidates who were maybe gonna get into
the race we'll get to that in a second
even Saturday Night Live which is as
left's left wing and establishment as it
gets is willing to admit at this point
that the candidates aren't that great is
that there was a pretty funny send up
that they did and SNL doesn't do very
funny stuff these days but it was pretty
funny it was pretty fair here is the SNL
take on Budaj edge and Bernie
muda jej looks like he's five years old
and he has no black support so this
isn't a devastating attack from them
it's not like they hate Peabody judge
and they want to wreck his candidacy
like they would for some other
candidates but it is acknowledging this
guy's a little bit weak and it's
acknowledging actually that racial issue
which we were talking about with regard
to Trump not five minutes ago they're
recognizing that is a major weakness so
they're not trying to kill him they're
not saying he's an evil candidate or
he's a bad bad candidate we got to get
rid of him but they are saying he's weak
he's young he's probably not gonna make
it over the finish line what are they
making fun of with Bernie Sanders
they're making fun of the fact that
Bernie Sanders is extremely old and just
had a heart attack but he's still a
hardcore left
okay pretty mild attacks then they move
on to Kamala Harris and Cory Booker so
Kamala Harris they're basically
discarding they're saying she's not a
serious candidate she needs a Jif to
break away she needs a viral loan
otherwise she's going nowhere then Joe
Biden
they say he's just kind of losing his
marbles and he's saying things that are
considered offensive he's old he's past
his prime not just in terms of his age
but also ideologically Cory Booker same
thing the Cory Booker is this sort of
race pandering candidate who is trying a
little too hard he's always bringing up
black churches he's always he's really
trying to harp on that aspect of his
candidacy but it's not really playing
well it's coming off as disingenuous
he's not at his heart of hearts and
identity politics
candidate he if he were really running
to be the sort of candidate that would
give him the best chance of becoming a
nominee it would be more unifying it
would be more moderate it would be it
more honest it would be more earnest
then they get to Joe Biden and Tulsi
Gabbard the attacks get even harsher so
with Joe Biden there they're going after
him harder than they have in the past
that he's not just losing it that he's
not just past his prime ideologically
and physically but that he's also a liar
too he's a liar he's making up stories
he made up the story about corn pop and
the way that they're satirizing this is
by saying that he's he's one half of
Errol danpalm are going to White Castle
now it's not a it's not a fatal attack
it's not a devastating attack as they
still make him likable while he's
telling the story they're kind of
hedging their bets on whether or not Joe
Biden's gonna get the nomination frankly
I am too they reserved their real twist
the knife attack for Tulsi Gabbard
they're saying explicitly she is a
villain she was a bad person she's good
she gained strength on the weakness and
fear of her victims so they really don't
like Tulsi Gabbard okay other than the
Tulsi hit they're all sort of light
little jabs but they're not exalting any
of the left-wing candidates as they have
done in the past
SNL historically picks a candidate and
doesn't get any real attack in on them I
mean think about how they how they
satirized Hillary Clinton in 26
team the only thing even nearing an
attack they made on her was that she
should have endorsed redefining marriage
earlier other than that it was all
really light stuff and then when she
lost kate mckinnon who played Hillary
Clinton cried at a piano I think she was
playing hallelujah it's just so sad and
so pathetic
but what's strange in this election
cycle is they're now starting to tell
jokes about all of the candidates early
on the candidate they really weren't
going after they were exalting her in
almost exactly the same way that they
did to Hillary Clinton was Elizabeth
Warren
but after Elizabeth Warren's debate
performance they actually got in the
real hit on her they made a joke about
how she lied about her Native American
ancestry this hit is still has a lot of
the elements of the typical Saturday
Night Live's favorite candidate hit but
it's got a little twist at the end so
what are they what is it before the maze
comment before the Native American
comment what are they making fun of her
for they're making fun of her for being
over ambitious oh yeah that's a good one
they're making fun of her for being too
prepared yeah okay that's a good one
they're making fun of her for being kind
of like mom at Thanksgiving she's kind
of like mom that's supposed to be a an
attack I mean it's it's like in a job
interview when you go in and they say
what's your biggest weakness and you say
I work too hard as though that's a
weakness I'm too dedicated to my job
yeah that's a win so that's that's how
SNL typically attacks their favorite
candidate they say she's too good she's
too smart she's too prepared and they
are still doing that because liz warren
is still their favorite candidate but
now they're willing to actually make the
joke sort of the joke is she's a total
race hustling liar the whitest woman and
planet Earth who's pretending to be
Satchmo not say not Satchmo different
kind of race hustling that would be
she's pretending to be Squanto and and
she's not she's obviously not how do
they get the attackin they get the
attack in because they set up the
Thanksgiving joke they are so
uncomfortable to make this attack that
she says I'm gonna make my old native
Amer
and ancestry should I say it I don't
want to say it should I say it Mays Mays
being and a traditional Native American
food if they really wanted to make the
attack they would have used the phrase
powwow Chow which is an actual recipe
that Elizabeth Warren actually submitted
to an actual Native American cookbook I
know it sounds like it isn't I know it
sounds like a joke that would be on SNL
but she actually did that because she is
a shameless race hustling liar they
didn't go for that joke that would be a
little too real that would be a little
too hard so they said May's okay what's
funny is that the SNL joke is actually
much more staid it's much more reserved
and much more believable than the actual
recipe that she submitted to the Native
American cookbook however all of that
said Elizabeth Warren is losing some
steam she's been the candidate with all
of the momentum for the last month at
least she's starting to lose some steam
why well in part it's because she's not
doing terribly well among minority
voters especially among black voters on
whom the Democrats have relied for
decades - and I think this is even more
decisive it's because she released her
ridiculous health care plan she released
that health care plan the details of it
and people laughed in her face because
it's absurd
she said she's gonna pay for her health
care plan by making those billionaires
pay just you know two cents more the
health care plan cost fifty two trillion
dollars the combined wealth of every
billionaire in America is about 3.7
trillion dollars so you get about 65
percent of the way through the first
year of her health care plan even if you
rob every billionaire of every Paves guy
you still have nothing left
sixty-five percent into the first year
of that health care plan what do you do
then it's completely unserious and
you've now got more more serious
Democrats looking at her and saying nope
she's not the one that's the donor class
that's the operative class that's the
big boss class because don't forget the
Democratic Party is controlled by party
that's was true back in the days of boss
tweed in Tammany Hall and it's true now
in the day of super-delegates
so her store is beginning to fade you're
seeing that reflected on Saturn an alive
and in all of this you have the answer
to a question that nobody was asking
Mike Bloomberg officially declaring that
he is running for president as a
Democrat that's what the Democrats want
a billionaire X politician who hasn't
been in politics for years and years who
is absolutely moderate compared to this
field that's what the Democrats want I
don't think so
we'll go through his pathetic
announcement video and then we will get
to some news from Ruth Bader Ginsberg
and the game the Harvard Yale football
game but first I got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube if you are craving
more of my mellifluous tones then you
have not been listening to another
kingdom maybe you have been but you want
more another kingdom another kingdom is
Andrew Clayton's fantasy podcast and
it's performed by me it's the last job
I'm ever going to get in Hollywood
because you know the rest of the town
that's so much on my political views not
so happy about them you got to go check
it out daily wiry calm and subscribe
right now to catch up because today
Tuesday at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
drew and I will be sitting down together
to discuss the final season and to take
subscriber questions live from the
listeners this live event will be free
for everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube but only subscribers will be
able to ask the questions at daily
wired.com Plus subscribers exclusively
can watch the entire series or you can
listen to the newest seasons for free on
Apple podcasts go check it out don't
miss another Kingdom live discussion
happening today at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
it's like that meme that goes around on
Twitter you say nobody says nothing
literally nobody says nothing Mike
Bloomberg says I'm running for president
as a Democrat is the answer to the
question no one was asking it's actually
not quite fair there is a question right
now of is there a Democrat that can be
President Trump because this entire
field of what was once about 25
candidates has not been able to rise to
that challenge now of course Mike
Bloomberg cannot be Donald Trump for
president Mike Bloomberg I'm not sure
that he would win any states if he
somehow I mean I guess he would win New
York or something I don't know it
depends how this race shakes out it
would be very hard to imagine a world in
which Mike Bloomberg is elected
president of the United States he's
wanted to run for decades he's been
trying to run since 2008 at least he's
now officially doing it he'd made moves
to try to do it to register in certain
states he has now announced his campaign
I think he's probably the least
appealing candidate in the race but
you've got to see how he's pitching his
candidacy because what his campaign
pitch shows is that the the Democrats
the left are even more disconnected from
the reality of politics in the Trump era
than we thought because at first
we've just been seeing this insane
leftward lurch among the Democratic
candidates which is likely to doom them
in the general election that's been the
sort of fantasy of politics that they've
been engaging in so far but what we see
here in the Mike Bloomberg campaign
pitch is that they're deluding
themselves in an entirely different way
here's Bloomberg Mike Bloomberg started
as a middle-class kid who had to work
his way through college then built a
business from a single room to
entity creating tens of thousands of
good-paying jobs along the way he could
have stopped there but when New York
suffered the terrible tragedy of 9/11 he
took charge becoming a three-term mayor
who brought a city back from the ashes
and brought back jobs and hope with it
okay a huge mistake right off the bat
first of all Mike Bloomberg is a very
impressive guy I mean he built his
business up from nothing to become a
dominant force in both media and finance
he's a very sharp very impressive guy he
was an okay mayor of New York I mean I'm
a New Yorker
it was in New York when he was mayor
Giuliani was much much better Giuliani
is probably the greatest mayor in the
history of New York maybe one or two
exceptions Mike Bloomberg lived off the
fumes of Giuliani as New York and then
he added a bunch of stupid nanny state
regulations like he can't drink sodas he
can't drink big gulps and you can't
smoke in public and so it's kind of
annoying can't smoke in bars he was the
kind of annoying mayor of New York but
he was fine he managed it well enough
he's much better than the Bolshevik
currently in Gracie Mansion in New York
now the mistake he made is describing
his political career which at this point
was centered around 2001 2002 18 years
ago when it's reminding voters is that
he's old and he's not gonna convince
voters that he got in New York through
9/11 he didn't everyone knows that Rudy
Giuliani got New York through 9/11
that's how he became America's mayor and
guess what that strategy didn't work for
Giuliani 12 years ago remember
Giuliani ran for president 2008 so you
got his campaign going in 2007 and his
whole campaign was I was mayor during
9/11 Joe Biden made fun of him Joe Biden
said that a Rudy Giuliani sentence
includes a noun of urban 9/11 and even
then what it showed voters was mm this
guy's kind of old news
because even in 2008 9/11 was seven
years prior they said okay that's kind
of an amazing thing that he did but
that's just there was just one data
point and it's kind of old now we're so
many years later not a good strategy if
it didn't work for Giuliani it's not
gonna work for Bloomberg
reminds people that he's old and he's
washed up politically speaking you got
to remember Mike Bloomberg is 77 years
old he's nine months older than Joe
Biden he is an old man he seems much
more with it than Joe Biden that's for
sure but again it's sort of damning with
faint praise bill weld who I was running
for mayor for president against Donald
Trump in the Republican primary I don't
know that he's still in it he might be
if he is or he isn't it doesn't really
matter bill weld launched his campaign
by saying bill weld was the governor of
Massachusetts in like the 1840s I used
governor of Massachusetts in the early
90s and you see that and first of all
you see in the pictures that this guy is
so much older than me he was when he was
governor and you also think he's so past
his prime the political issues we're
talking about today are completely
different from the issues that we were
talking about then not a good start
Bloomberg then goes on to make the pitch
on his policy platform creating tens of
thousands of affordable housing units so
families could have a decent place to
live raising teachers salaries and kids
graduation rates and creating a more
open and liveable city for the millions
who call it home
open and livable city and we sang that
he's holding a gay pride flag walking in
a ostensibly a gay pride parade this
raises the question who is Mike
Bloomberg's constituency he's making the
same mistake that all billionaires make
I've for some reason I've had the
privilege of meeting a few billionaires
over the years and one thing I've
noticed about the majority of them is
they believe not all of them but at
least the ones I know from New York they
believe that what America is really
yearning for is a candidate who's
fiscally conservative and socially
liberal he doesn't get hung up on all
those silly social issues like killing a
million babies a year or redefining
marriage the bedrock of civilization
yeah you don't get hung up on that stuff
liberals can have that he realized that
what Americans really want is lower
taxes all right and polls show that
statistically
nobody wants that policy platform people
who want a presidential candidate is
fiscally conservative and social liberal
in other words a greedy Democrat is
about 4.5% like nobody and I think most
of those 4.5% are extraordinarily
wealthy people in New York so he's
making this pitch to fiscal fiscal
conservative social liberals that's
nobody that's not gonna work it's also
the pride flag is not a great idea to
get in there because it's gonna turn off
a lot of people after the LGBTQ movement
has become the symbol of what you would
call oppressive liberalism I mean the
drag queen story hour and sex education
teaching your kids about disgusting
things when they're in kindergarten and
confusing people on sex and gender it's
just not a good look the whole argument
for a Bloomberg candidacy is that these
Democrats are too left-wing to win in
the general I'm a more moderate guy and
I'm pragmatic and I've accomplished a
lot vote for me and he's just not able
to really make that argument because he
is quite liberal on social issues he's
he's not going to win over conservatives
because he created jobs if you want a
job-creating conservative president you
got Donald Trump but he's not gonna win
over liberals by campaigning on economic
pragmatism liberals don't want economic
pragmatism the majority of Millennials
are identifying as socialists that's the
majority of Millennials overall of all
political stripes certainly among
Democratic primary voters so he's just
he's giving himself a constituency of
nobody then he makes the pitch from the
pragmatic managerial experience that
only King Michael Bloomberg can give you
he could have stopped there but when he
witnessed the terrible toll of gun
violence he put his money where his
heart is hoping to create a movement to
take on the NRA and the politicians they
own to protect families across this
country and help
the tide and he's funded college
education for thousands of deserving
low-income and middle-class kids and
supported life-saving medical research
and stood up to the coal Lobby and the
outright denial of this administration
to protect the only home we have from
the growing menace of climate change
King Michael K Michael Bloomberg he only
he can do it he has donated his own
money out of the goodness of his heart
to push all of these sort of oppressive
often unconstitutional programs on the
American people he is able to do it
because of his largesse and because he's
got a lot of confidence and a big ego
and a lot of institutional power that's
right folks we need to defeat Donald
Trump and that's why the only way we can
do it is by electing an egomaniac
billionaire from New York [ __ ] is that
hey hey do you hate Donald Trump well
vote for me the poor man's Donald Trump
hey do you guys give me a break and and
and then you get the final pitch of this
which is actually on the ideological
plane this is where it all falls apart
here's that here's the final here's the
last thrust if Bloomberg didn't win you
over so far maybe you didn't hear it is
now you're not gonna be able to resist
voting for him now he sees different
kind of menace coming from Washington so
there's no stopping here because there's
an America waiting to be rebuilt where
everyone without health insurance is
guaranteed to get it and everyone who
likes theirs can go ahead and keep it
where the wealthy will pay more in taxes
and the struggling middle class will get
their fair share and jobs that just
allow you to get by will become jobs
that let you get ahead
Mike Bloomberg for president jobs
creator leader problem solver it's going
to take all three to build back a
country this is so lame it's so lame
because on the ideological front what
this pitch is to the American people is
the same as saying hey vote for Mike
Bloomberg because he's going to give you
the exact status quo but you'll get a
little bit more money vote for the
status quo with slightly lower taxes and
a little bit more money and the
billionaires they'll pay like a little
bit more in taxes not too much but a
little bit vote for Mike Bloomberg
and nothing will change so he just
doesn't understand that on both the left
and the right right now I think people
are realizing that the status quo that
we've had for now what 30 40 years is
coming to an end the status quo you
could call it whatever you want call it
neoliberalism call it the post-war
consensus call it the post Cold War
consensus call it whatever you want
that's coming to an end because it's
created some new pride was great
worked out for a long time and now it
has created some new problems that a new
generation of politicians are going to
have to address problems caused by mass
migration problems if you're on the left
that you would call wealth inequality or
climate change or what right these
problems whether they're real or
imaginary these are the problems that
are the result of the very politics that
Mike Bloomberg is trying to preserve and
nobody is going to go to the polls
because Mike Bloomberg says that wealthy
people are gonna pay a little bit more
in taxes nobody is going to go to the
polls because Bloomberg says you're
gonna get a little bit of a raise in
your same job that you don't really like
you're gonna get a $2 raise or something
that is not going to convince anybody
but Democrats have nothing else that's
all they can think of because they're
radical politics are extraordinarily
unpopular
whereas president Trump's rat
politics are pretty pretty popular he's
talking about issues that people care
about the negative effects of mass
migration the negative effects of
unfettered free trade and mortgaging our
country out to China giving them all of
our manufacturing and having them buy up
all of our debt he's addressing real
problems with relatively more popular
solutions puts the left in a bad
position I mean just look at the
hysteria over the weekend because Ruth
Bader Ginsburg was in the hospital
Justice Ginsburg who is you know a
little little long in the tooth she's a
woman of a certain age we will say and
she's had a good life and a good career
the left is pinning all of their hopes
on her so when she was admitted to the
hospital for fever and chills they lost
their minds she was trending on Twitter
if your entire political program hinges
on an elderly Supreme Court justice and
you've got pretty much no other hope and
nothing else to offer the American
people you are in serious trouble and it
was so ghoulish it was so ghastly
because think about what they're really
saying the whole trend about Ginsburg
can't die she can't die before Trump
leaves office she's got to stay there
please put her on life support the whole
point of that is so that the left can
keep killing a million babies a year
that's it that's what it's all about
it's only about Roe vs. Wade we see this
throughout every Supreme Court
confirmation hearing all they care about
is still being allowed through a
completely fictional constitutional
right to kill 1 million babies per year
what one woman must live so that many
others may die that is such a dead
program I mean that is such a I guess
pun pun not intended actually but it's
so it's such a hollow desiccated
political agenda everything else we have
three branches of government we got
federal we got state government we got
local government we got all of these
institutions of our government and
because the left has just completely
lost the narrative that completely lost
the point there now pinning all of their
hopes and their hopes are really really
ghoulish on this one elderly Supreme
Court justice who is appointed by Bill
Clinton I mean it's
just it's a whole political movement now
about nothing other than a couple of
these little interests that are are
pretty repugnant to people I mean just
look just look at the harvard-yale
football game the harvard-yale football
game was over the weekend I did not
attend it's actually usually a pretty
fun game because the tailgating gets
pretty raucous and then nobody actually
watches the football game and then
everybody leaves and goes home this year
I'm sorry I missed it this year not
because of the football I mean Yale won
good job way to go guys but because in
the middle of the game the whole game
was interrupted by a protest of climate
change sort of over 150 Yale and Harvard
students alumni and faculty stormed the
field to demand divestment from fossil
fuels to stop climate change you showed
them guys
you showed climate change by protesting
Harvard and Yale and then bizarrely the
protest of climate change became a
protest of Puerto Rican debt a kid
you're not here it is canceled the debt
Porto Rican debt because what they
wanted was for the Yale and Harvard
investment offices it's got to remember
Yale and Harvard have tens of billions
of dollars in their endowments I mean
these are hedge funds because like it's
sizable hedge funds do and so what these
yelling Harvard students are saying is
that most of whom I bet are on financial
aid like I was so they're actually
they're very likely because of the
results of the Investment Office but
they're now criticizing the Investment
Office and saying you can't invest in
fossil fuels or Puerto Rican debt you
can't invest in companies that hold
Puerto Rican debt Puerto Rico a very
corrupt island which has mismanaged a
lot of its funds and mismanaged its
hurricane recovery funds and so they've
got a lot of dead and then companies are
buying up that debt to allow Puerto Rico
to continue to exist and you've got to
divest from that they've got nothing the
left has got nothing they don't even
know what their protein
what are they what are what are they
angry about it's just it's not an
intellectual argument that the left is
making whether it's at the Democratic
debates or in the impeachment hearings
or at the harvard-yale football game
it's not an intellectual argument it's
just random ideological spasms the
climate change that were to Rican debt
what are just words they're just saying
words that don't have any meaning in in
any context of an argument they're just
saying random things because the left
has nothing and actually just to put one
final point on it before we go I've got
to get to the dumbest article on the
Internet today tonic easy coats in the
New York Times the cancellation of Colin
Kaepernick the long and short of it is
Tana hazy coats a MacArthur Genius the
guy who wrote about why we need to give
the descendants of black slaves
reparations in America that guy is
saying that Colin Kaepernick has been a
victim of canceled culture and this is a
terrible awful thing and it's it doesn't
make any sense here's the essence of his
argument cancel culture is not new any
sober assessment of the history of
America must conclude that the present
objections to cancel culture are not so
much concerned with the weapon as the
kind of people who now seek to wield it
quote until recently cancellation flowed
exclusively downward from the powerful
to the powerless but now in this era of
fallen gatekeepers where anyone with a
Twitter handle or Facebook account can
be a publisher banishment has been
ostensibly democratized this doesn't
make any sense just on its face it but
it's the same kind of gripes about
oppression and the powerful and the
powerless by definition cancel culture
will flow from the powerful to the
powerless whether it's flowing from a
corporate executive or from the
Democratic social media mob the people
who get cancelled or by definition
become the powerless and the people who
are able to do the cancelling are the
powerful this is not just a matter of
class
or money or race or any other way you
want to play a down any politics it's in
the act itself but then he gets to the
heart of the NFL's problem he says the
NFL is revered in this country as a
paragon of patriotism and chivalry a
sacred trust controlled by some of the
wealthiest men and women in America for
the past three years this sacred trust
has executed with brutal efficiency the
cancellation of Colin Kaepernick this is
curious given them the NFL's moral
Liberty nism the league has at various
points been a home for domestic abusers
child abusers and open racists fair
enough that's all true either a lot of
Darrell lakes that have played in the
NFL and yet it seems mr. Kaepernick's in
refusing to stand for the national
anthem offends the NFL's
suddenly delicate sensibilities and
while the influence of hashtags should
not be underestimated the NFL has a
different power at its fingertips the
power of Monopoly Kaepernick's
cancellation bars him from making a
living in a skill he has been honing
since childhood cry me a river for Colin
Kaepernick that's not what happened at
all here's what happened
Colin Kaepernick disrespected not just
some aspect of America but the whole
country itself by disrespecting the
national anthem which is called the
star-spangled banner which is the flag
which is the symbol of the whole country
and then guess what it turns out the
people who watch America's new favorite
pastime who tune in to watch sporting
events which have always had a patriotic
aspect to them but especially football
in this day and age the people who tuned
in to watch that didn't like it they
don't like it when you disrespect their
whole country and so they didn't want to
watch him and Colin Kaepernick lost that
job and then he made millions of dollars
with Nike pitching sneakers and trying
to get Betsy Ross canceled that is not
an aspect of canceled culture it is
actually an demonstration of the cause
of so much of our social strife which is
you've got multi multi-millionaire Colin
Kaepernick who played in one of the most
elite professions you can possibly be
employed in being the subject of writing
by Tana heezy Coates a man who has lived
an unbelievably luxurious elite life won
the MacArthur Genius grant writing in
the New York Times bestselling author
and all these two guys can do is
complain and pretend to
victims Yale and Harvard students at one
of the most elite sporting events in the
world the Yale Harvard football game all
they can do is complain and pretend to
be victims those candidates up on the
Democratic stage all they can do is
pretend that woe is me everybody is a
victim everybody's being oppressed
it's just BS people know that that isn't
true even the New York Times comment
section was making fun of time and easy
codes for this column
it's just BS they've lost the narrative
they've got nothing there huffing and
puffing even through impeachment they've
got nothing what argument will they make
going into 2020 I suspect the left won't
have an argument to make it will be more
shrill sighs shrieks and hysteria and in
the meantime we can keep making serious
arguments to the American people I think
we're we've lost a lot of reason as a
culture we've lost a lot of civility but
I think that between a reasonable
argument to the voters interests and
huffing and puffing and screeching about
sir reality I think the great
conservative consolation will hold I
think reality will win that's our show
I'm Michael nose this is Michael Noel's
show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by my core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you